♪ (ETHEREAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ZENDAYA: It's special, like,
the show is really special.
So, to kind of see it
turn into what it turned into
it just, I don't know...
not to get all sad and stuff,
but...
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Well I just knew the moment
that I read the script,
it was so immersive.
I called my mom and I said,
"This is exactly
what I want to play."
(SCREAMS)
The fact that labels
are sort of left out
of the story
is one of my favorite elements.
(TYPEWRITER KEYS CLICKING,
DINGS)
There's so many characters
to relate to
and identities to follow.
♪ You will fall so hard ♪
ZENDAYA: After I watched
the pilot I was like,
"Yo, like, it's brilliant."
I was terrified to watch it,
like I-- probably,
like the rest of our cast,
had a mild panic attack
but I enjoyed it so much,
and I was so proud
of what we were doing.
DIRECTOR: Great, cut it.
ALEXA DEMIE: It's really cool
to be able to work with Sam,
being really specific
with shots and direction.
♪ 'Bout to make a big deal
Uproar ♪
♪ And I'm in for the kill
La Roux ♪
What's amazing about Sam
is that he listens to us
and what we went through,
and writes true to that.
So there's a lot of flavor,
a lot of creative freedom
that we experience on set.
From Sam, to every producer,
to every castmate,
every crew person.
You just feel the love.
-Oh shit, I dropped my glasses.
-(CHUCKLES)
And we just honestly
had a lot of fun.
Working with Z, and Alexa,
and Maude,
and everybody a part of this,
I've created this new family.
It just has been
an absolute dream.
ALGEE SMITH:
We've been carnival chillin',
you know what I'm sayin'?
Big popcorn eatin',
you feel what I'm sayin'?
-ZENDAYA: (CHUCKLES) I'm cold.
-WOMAN: Oh my gosh, little feet!
It's some of the best time
of my life.
It felt like we'd known
each other for like ten years.
-(CHUCKLES) Why is this funny?
-It's not funny.
We just bought a house,
this is our view.
Maddy and Nate kind of
stayed with us
-throughout the process.
-(CHUCKLES)
It made all of the traumatic
work that we had to do better.
It felt really good.
♪ Wish you
Wish you'd come home ♪
ZENDAYA: Our last day
of shooting was such
a weird bundle of emotions.
Everybody was so happy
and excited to be there.
DIRECTOR:
Here we go, let's roll.
ZENDAYA: But then it was also
like (SIGHS)
everything's coming
to an end.
Like, it's our last day.
(CROWD CHEERING)
I'm like, "No, no,
like I'm good.
Like, we'll see each other
and it's fine,
like I'm not gonna
get emotional."
♪ You're still so close
Yet so far ♪
DIRECTOR: That is a season one
Euphoria wrap.
♪ I still don't know my name ♪
ZENDAYA:
It's just become very special
to me, not only in like,
a work sense but in
a personal sense, you know?
♪ And I would die or stay ♪
HUNTER SCHAFER: A lot of love
is in this project.
I think it's really exciting
to like,
see where it can go.
♪ Still don't know my name ♪
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪